I'm going to get some pie
Are you going to order something or.
And now here we are enjoying a meal.
Like gentle.
You slap me in the face.
I'm not going to get you a shake. Okay?
this crack?
Is it?
Whatever we do,
we're playing God
be our gods.
But how do you choose
who lives
and who dies?
Think the hard choice.
You better
walk away.
Come on.
You're the God of mischief.
Always have been and always will be.
Over the top, don't you think?
I thought it was spot on.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
They have another new Loki season 2
trailer with more footage of them at that
McDonald's in the 1970s,
seeming like it confirms
they also capture the zany character in
and still be hiding out,
pretending to be a regular worker
there in the same episode.
we also learn
more about the real villain of season two.
And it's actually not supposed
to be one of the King variants
even though a lot of Victor
Timely Kang is in the trailer,
it seems like he's going to be
one of the big villains
with his version of Miss Minutes.
supposedly that's going to be a misdirect.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course
I'll be doing episodes
just like season one.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Look at the Asoka episodes
starting next week too,
and I'll be doing episode videos for that.
we're finally getting
some brand new stuff.
end, even though you shouldn't
hold your breath,
it seems like there's a good chance
that all the strike stuff might
get figured out by the time Loki season
two episodes get started,
usually with stuff like that,
you don't want to speak too soon,
which is why I've avoided making like
a bigger video about the strike stuff.
But it seems like most people expect
that to get figured out by October
But someone spotted this Loki themed
McDonald's sauce in the wild recently.
So this seems like a thing you'll actually
be able to buy at real life.
McDonald's at some point.
But I haven't seen any details
about how they're going to handle that
Good luck to everyone.
I think they're eager for everyone
to forget about the whole Rick and Morty
one incident from several years ago.
But in the actual context of the series,
I think this whole McDonald's thing
is kind of like the Rick and Morty thing
where it was only at the very beginning
and then they never reference it again.
within the context of the actual episodes,
it seems like by the time
this is happening, like the by the time
they eat the actual McDonald's,
Loki has already stopped time slipping
or he's at least figured out
what's going on.
They started to fix the issue
and he's already
explained the Kang Multiverse War
and what happened during season one with
he who remains Kang to Mobius,
all the other friendly agents
who are helping them,
who were part of the new rebooted timeline
and thus don't remember
anything from season one
That's what a lot of this footage is of
him revealing Kang behind these thoughts.
Like killing the timekeepers.
No, no, no.
We got rid of this during season one.
We figured this out. These are all fake.
in. At least at some point, they started
going on regular missions again.
Now, remember,
this is still pretty early on
in the series
to stop the most dangerous Nexus events.
Zany Act
being one of the first ones they go after.
It seems like don't be surprised
if this zany stuff finding
silver happens by the end of episode
one or episode two.
I don't think they want to go very long
without actually bringing the Sylvie
character back.
So it's not like they're going to wait
to the end of the series
to actually bring her back
also because it's rumored
that the actual main villain is a secret.
Main villain of the series
is not one of the Kang variants.
Loki and Mobius are just going
after a different Kang variant
because Loki is trying to deal
with the Kang Multiverse War
they're still super dangerous,
something they're trying to deal with.
But while that's happening, they have to
deal with an older Sylvie variant
who's supposed to be played by Kate
Dickie.
Most of you will probably remember her
from Game of Thrones.
She played Caitlin Stark's sister,
Lysa Aaron She was sweet.
Robin's mother, pretty crazy character.
Also sounds like she's going to be
pretty crazy during Loki season two.
but unlike the older Loki variant
during season one of the other Loki
that helped them she's supposed to be
a more chaotic older version of Sylvie.
I think the idea is that
she's a future version of her who's grown
remorseful for what she did, killing her
remains in the chaos that that caused
because it freed the counsel of Kang,
started another Kang Multiverse war,
which they're actually covering
during Avengers five.
Kane Dynasty.
they've been hyping up the Kang
Multiverse War, like the original version
that Loki learned about during season one,
and now the second version so much
they're actually kind of waiting
to do that on screen as part of Avengers
five with like $300 million.
that's
meant to pay off the council of Kang's
going after everyone
trying to destroy the heroes
other characters that try to stop them
or threaten their supremacy.
Mostly the main MCU characters play
a couple of multiverse characters too.
Maybe deadpool's in that
most of the multiverse cameo scenes like
Andrew Garfield, Tobey Maguire coming back
like the X-Men characters coming back
for Secret Wars beyond Deadpool three.
Most of Avengers five
I think is main MCU characters, though
the older Sylvie variant
I think is meant to be a version of this.
Sylvie They just lived through that
and is trying to prevent it from happening
by working in the past
to get rid of all the timelines
she thinks belong to the Council of Kang's
Now, it's not totally clear
from the trailer footage
what she might be doing that
the Loki and younger Sylvie feel like
they need to stop.
It might just be the older
Sylvie is destroying
all kinds of timelines, creating
all this chaos and causing time itself
to come unraveled like a rope.
She might be destroying innocent
people are threatening all of reality.
Otherwise,
if she's just trying to get rid of the
Council of Kings, do you think that Loki
and younger Sylvie would love that?
Like, Yes,
please do get rid of all those kings.
So there has to be some sinister twist
with this older Sylvie end,
even though they have
a ton of footage of Kahui queens
or a Burrows character in the trailers,
I don't think he's doing anything
beyond just helping them fix the timeline.
In Loki's time slipping.
He's meant to be like
the main tech guy at the TVA.
His office is supposed to be
at the very bottom levels.
Like when they hit the elevator,
they hit the very bottom button.
So it seems like he's
most critical to the plot,
at least in the first few episodes
where all this craziness is happening
and things start unraveling because
the timeline is literally unraveling.
you notice, this happening to Sylvie
in the 1970s, while simultaneously
happening inside the TVA,
which itself exists
and sort of like a pocket dimension.
So it's affecting all of reality,
not just a single timeline
patch that timeline up with some really,
really hard core duct tape, flex tape,
the multiverse got a lot of questions
about what's going on with the Zenia
character, too, because he's super twisty.
He's being played by Rafael Casal
that most of your recognize from
Blindspotting Zenia is a super deep
cut for the Thor comics.
That's why they're using him on Loki,
because Loki is a Thor character
but he started out as a nameless,
evil entity from the dark dimension
that Dormammu sent to Earth
to cause pain and suffering.
That was his whole reason.
Remember,
this is Dormammu from Doctor Strange.
Dormammu sends the zany entity
to the 1800s on Earth
where he possessed the man who became
the Marvel version of Jack the Ripper.
So in the Marvel Universe,
this is canonical.
zany, and was responsible for all the Jack
the Ripper murders.
after that host died,
it possessed the body of a regular actor.
Brad Wolf in the 20th century.
Causes him to do kind of the same thing,
go on this wild rampage
with Thor having to stop him now
the big Meadow twist here,
like we joke about the fake in universe
Marvel movies.
They did that during Spider-Man
far from home.
In some of the more recent Marvel movies.
You just see
a bunch of actors in the Marvel Universe,
like canonical actors making movies
based on events in the Marvel Universe,
but parodies of real life Marvel movies.
This Brad Wolfe character in the Marvel
Universe works kind of the same way,
kind of like the Wonder Man character who
makes movies inside the Marvel Universe.
but the movies themselves are parodies of
things that Marvel has done in real life.
the Easter egg. They're playing on here,
though. Is it?
The Brad Wolfe character in the comics
was possessed by the zany entity
while he was in the middle
of making a movie about zany act.
So it's meant to be this ironic twist.
the actor becomes the very character
he was pretending to be,
and that's kind of
what's going on in the trailer.
It seems like Loki, Moby Mobius
probably learn about something
similar happening with a huge Nexus event
that they're trying to stop in.
Raphael Cassel is probably playing
the Bad Wolf actor who's in danger
of turning into zany or doing something
really crazy that causes the next event.
there's probably a few Nexus events.
They try to stop like this
before they find out
about the real threat
of this older Sylvie.
And it seems like after they captured
the Zenia character in the 1970s,
they also learn about Sylvie
and McDonald's
because they're in the same 1970s period
at this McDonald's
They convince her to come back and that's
when they find out about Victor time.
We can go back to the 1890s World's
Fair in Chicago to stop him.
There's tons of footage of that
in the trailer.
Victor Timely Kang
is probably like episode three,
maybe episode four,
somewhere in the middle of the series,
at least with the final few episodes, them
going after the older Sylvie.
In my early theory right now
for the end of season two
is that they do stop older Sylvie
but we know that Avengers
five Qing Dynasty is still happening.
We know the Council of Kang
still has another Kang Multiverse war,
so they don't stop any of that,
that's probably part of the WTF ending.
Look, another teaser for Avengers
five still happening
then being unsuccessful
in stopping the Council of Kings.
Maybe a Deadpool three teaser
because so much of that series
crosses over with Loki.
It happens after Loki Season
two about not expecting Deadpool
to show up during Loki season two.
there wasn't anything about Loki Season
three yet even if they started filming it
early next year,
all the strike stuff gets figured out.
I don't think they'd be able to finish it
before Avengers five,
so if they do season three,
it might take place either
after Secret Wars or more likely
between Qing Dynasty in Secret Wars.
Ju seems way more interesting,
like the craziness and chaos of them
trying to deal with Battle World during
the ending of the Kang Multiverse War 2.0.
You don't want to skip over something
like that.
It'd be like
skipping over Avengers Endgame.
but if they do season three, I think that
would be the likely end of the series.
Only because Marvel seems really keen
to move past all this multiverse
saga stuff and get to more core X-Men
main Universe stuff.
But if you do have any questions
about what's going on with Loki,
the other upcoming Marvel stuff,
just post them in the comments below.
I'll try to address everything
in the comments and big reminder.
My Asoka episodes start next week.
Click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 video Talking about Channing
Tatum coming is Gambit in a
whole bunch of other cameos and click here
for all my Loki season two videos.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!